It's now people are going be ready and
quick to just second guess anything that
you say. Yeah, that's, that's a fact.
Until we can read each other's minds
till we could find out for sure that's
going to change the whole game.
The reason why his mind. Yeah,
that's definitely gonna eliminate a
lot of street fights. Most of them.
You talk about your,
your imminent dangerous sensors are
going to be one up 100% if you read
somebody's mind. Yeah. Yeah. I don't
know if I want to do that. I do.
I like him. His secrets, no mall
in. I like having secrets too,
but I like going all in. I think all in,
I think, I think it's just inevitable.
We were talking about it in the last
podcast about there's something they're
going to be able to shoot into
your neck and what did he say?
The way you described it sounds like an
injection that will take over sort of,
well,
the way it interacts with your brain cells
thread thread itself and your brain's
house.
So literally like having,
I think we're going to have built in Wifi
Internet systems where we're connected
to each other's heads. So this what
people request was like a study.
They're going to try out on paper or
you can just go to your doctor and say,
shoot me with the brain shit.
I think eventually it's going to be
shooting me with the brain shit first.
You got to get it out on a clinical trial,
going to be able to be heroin addicts
and crack heads. Who Do you get for that?
Like who is close to no brain cells
and shit and that's when we try it on.
What was that movie?
There was a movie where a dude got
shot and they put some chip in his back
upgrade. Oh Great. Yeah,
and it did that to him.
It turned to be like an access to all
the information. He knew martial arts,
he knew how to move and
everything was happening.
He was a basically like a super
computer inside of a person that can do
everything. Artificial intelligence
is right down the line.
If they're talking about this shit,
shooting it in your brain,
we're going to share a network.
We're all going to be on a network.
It's going to be a lot of white people
joining that effort because black people
don't fuck with needles,
Bro.
We don't do lessons in our way.
We don't take out bro.
I'm telling you to say that, but how many,
how many athletes are on steroids? Yeah,
but that's a different,
that's a different animal.
I'm talking about the average black dude.
That's what Flynn, Brownsville or, okay.
Okay. Watch the stuff like that.
Yo, I got this new brain. Shit.
We injected through a needle. They go fuck
you up. They don't want hear that shit.
That's hilarious.
And that's probably true.
I mean how many people
are going to try that?
Like who's going to be the earliest
adopter getting a shot in your neck that
lets you read everybody's mind.
Then what are you going to do with it?
It's interesting.
It's going to fuck our job up man,
because like half of what we do is say
shocking shit that people know is kind of
true. But you can't believe you're
saying that people are always like, oh,
not feel winters. Subway Joe
coming up, you've got done.
If you could do that, that'd be the
ultimate fucking joke hater right there.
Oh yeah. Two guys walk in a bar. You
don't got anything other than that?
Nothing. I think I'll have to pass on it.
Keep it bro. Yeah, it's going to be weird.
When would you get it?
Like you wouldn't,
would you want to be the
first comedian to have it? Oh,
you almost want to be a
fool who doesn't have it.
If you want to be a comedian I to watch
other motherfuckers do it first. Yeah. Oh,
I'll sit in the back.
But the problem is they're going
to fucking take over like finances,
like instantly they're gonna.
As soon as they upload their
brand and they're like,
I'm just gonna get all this money,
I'm going to figure out a way
to get all this fucking money.
And then by the time you
shoot it into your head,
they've already got the system
locked down. We'll see. That's,
you have different level of people that
you hang out with because your level be
like, well how do we get the
money? But my level be like, Yo,
who got this brace yet? How are we
going to get some ass off at his dog?
You can get it. You'll be
more clever. Read abroad, man.
You get all the you all of
it. Yeah. You would know,
but then it wouldn't be fun
like half the fun is not known.
If somebody likes you, right? You
don't know what's going to happen here.
Is this going to work out.